ladies and gentlemen
welcome to Yale I'm very glad to have
you here
my name is pericles louis i'm the vice
president for global strategy of the
university and i'm delighted to welcome
you to this two-day conference on the
theme of brazilian studies in the united
states and this is a follow-up to a
smaller symposium we held here in May
which was a very lively opportunity to
think about the future of Brazilian
studies and to end to plan for this
larger conference this moment will
extend those discussions around specific
themes that allow for deeper analysis of
the topics and scholarship Yale has a
deep and rich relationship with Brazil
in fact some of our first international
students at Yale came from Brazil Jawad
Francisco Lima entered the Yale School
of Medicine in 1833 and since that date
Yale has continuously been involved in
educating Brazilian leaders furthermore
Brazil and its language and culture have
been important subjects of study unto
themselves here at Yale the teaching of
Portuguese began at the University in
the early days of the Second World War
when you began instituting area studies
programs in the mid 20th century and
you're in the midland center for
international and area studies which is
the later development of that phenomenon
one of the first programs instituted was
the Latin American Studies major in 1953
soon followed by the offering of
Portuguese first as an elective and then
in the 1990s as a major Yale's history
with Brazil has resulted in a vibrant
and growing alumni community which is
furthered by a variety of programs and
collaborations in Brazil including those
through the Council on Latin American
and Iberian studies the Yale Law School
the Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies the EBSCO public
health and the Yale School of Management
I'm glad to see that you'll be hearing
today and tomorrow from some of our
distinguished faculty members involved
in a few of these collaborative research
programs today's event is the result of
a collaborative effort between Yale and
the Ministry of Education in Brazil and
we're very excited to be able to
continue some of those conversations
over this weekend through our diverse
panels and and discussion questions
addressing a variety of topics I want to
say how grateful we are to mr. Jose la
Suarez de Silva the Minister of
Education of Brazil
to the hard-working staff at the
ministry for their support especially
the lead-based up Tory Seagal oh who
will be speaking to us shortly the
national deputy executive secretary it's
a pleasure to welcome back ambassador
Fernando meadow pareto an old friend now
I'd also like to recognize Carlos Yvonne
Simonson Leal the president of fund us
ow Tzeitel Oh
Vargas sorry for my Portuguese
pronunciation I have been to Brazil and
had a great time there but I didn't get
very deep into the language so you
notice an Italian accent you'll
understand and Marlowe bono Leto the
director and representative of UNESCO in
Brazil were grateful for their support
for this this conference as well and
here at Yale I'd like to thank professor
Claudia vallega chair of the Council on
Latin American Liberian Studies for
having the council take on the planning
for this conference under professors
David Jackson and Stuart sports for
bringing us all together and I think it
was really their vision that that is
being realized in this next couple of
days it's a great example of a
collaborative model with many
institutions being a part of the
organizational process I'm pleased that
this shows the continued importance of
Brazilian studies here at Yale and I
hope this relationship which began in
the 1830s or continues to thrive in in
the coming century and of course thank
thank you to all of you for being here
to our prominent scholars and panelists
from out from throughout the United
States and Brazil for representing your
various disciplines and for your
participation this weekend so we're
really honored to have you here I hope
that these are fruitful discussions and
I hope that Yale continues to
collaborate with your institutions to
strengthen Brazilian studies throughout
the United States and in Brazil thank
you
[Applause]
Thank You professor Lewis and thank you
all for coming in spite of this gray day
I I know some of us at least would like
to be in Baia right now but this is it
and thank you so much for attending this
wonderful gathering of people interested
in us Brazilian studies as the chair on
the Council on Latin American and
Iberian studies I would like to express
my gratitude to a lot of people and
particularly those who made this
possible who have helped in the planning
and coordination of this conference and
to those who will be participating as
panelists and moderators I'm very
excited about what in India gender for
us the breadth of topics is really
fascinating I'm looking forward to
attending all of the panels I would like
to especially thank professor David
Jackson and stor Schwartz here for
helping to convene this important
gathering and to our council and
Ministry of Education staff working
together on all of the organizational
aspects of putting the conference
together that were not minor and this is
a true proof of what a good
collaboration means I would like to
briefly introduce mr. Philippe's Sigala
here the representative from the
ministry of education of Brazil who will
give some welcome remarks philippi
Seagal Oh a civil engineer is currently
the national deputy executive secretary
of the Ministry of Education
Coordinating six national secretaries
subsidiaries of the ministry previously
mr. Segal has held a position of state
secretary of social development of Sao
Paulo
between 2015 and 2016 he also directed
the compañía police' the origins of
issues from 2011 and 2014 sorry my
argentinian Portuguese is but I promise
I will not talk about soccer
he has worked at the state of at the
state and municipal levels in Brazil a
state secretary as well as a deputy
mayor of two region of city of Sao Paulo
mr. Ziegler has over 15 years of
experience in public administration and
leadership and has been alongside great
managers and politicians always acting
in the execute avaria developing and
implementing governmental programs
welcome and thank you secretary siga
[Applause]
what are the todos Minami to Minister
dead concerned Brazil ho Saraswati's red
this year pleasant so she told me permit
on fine português she can marry a key
finding day my congruence at satsang
co-head torn okay universe that Gao Paz
and also conference Gao he Jewish McKee
Nova met Rosie Norris pescadores
professorial Uno's fascist posaga
decimate Aquino me the Minister Lucas
own University Gao offs of international
fair Universidad the consult Latin
America in various stages a witch named
Barry McMillan center for international
air history spell organization event
photography Smith special key Oh
professor Kennedy Dave Dave Jackson is
open
Blair Nelson singles our organization as
a conference been combo'd anterior or
front immense quake EP necessary
international Gustavo Seville actally
I dread the Satan being minister Carla
mahir to Audion cara cara de ser todo
todos presenters professors from chicago
venir a turkey compartir la otra ballet
pesky Syncom presenter perspectiva soba
de todos suburb receive a therapist keys
a carob purveyor grosseto BIA for
presidential fund associate Oliver goes
in special so president Carlos Aversa
mostly ow
Hinduja to the Fukuda gd2 professors a
jogger okay ambassador kid only first
dad you know Brazil categorisation also
present semester me apart say dear
Conchita construido press team allows us
to do Brasil aki-nee spice
Ready Set America tour down is Cano
Brazil my parts Paso important S&S
achieve yet at the scene compliment moon
special oh no so con su shirokino studs
Anita Murshid orphan and Jamel by hit
ambassador Emily Mary Ellen a Piero
Chevelle maroon to jar he Tama present
someone to tomato so me too
for Chucky sorry singles in my condo
Civic each report indicates arrogance
trabajo stones evolved is universe dad's
American a super Brazil in yoga Meszaros
to consummate nineteen Sandow do make
the ministerial Dukas own arrow villains
observe are estado totus Tuus over
Brazil okie no stars hoon is remote
injured entry card format similar stood
so blue Brasilia spice
paws momentum in rallies are the pelo
ministerio
serve at a sustained such a sentry
pesquisa jessalyn second estado needs
abort on Tomas can achieve so Brazil
strip widows in st. Rose course
especially those over America latina
demos interest sequencer malaria Poyer
Nessa movimento given David Academy no
sin square internal studs needs ego his
Vanessa please permit knowledge of man
as a bachelor decadence a saint
Quatro cerdos professor Thomas Skidmore
cuando Chile so temple a primera vez no
professor so liberal politics in Brazil
in unison society search the aging toe
important sensory room test coming bra
Austin Harvick in yo tambien Columbia
River aunt Ella que nos Linda casinos
been a quest event occurs Singh Kham
demise Universidad course Pescador esto
aqui presented nonsense tomatoes in
tandem skis to sob abrasion Estados
Unidos contribute officer Novoa re sobre
Brazil nos reverse computer coins made
no so desert Darin Paso mais Timo
sentence Township rosboroughs estos
Brazil Aires Aquino Estados Unidos
compromiso Smiths Peru Brazil magine da
Vinci
the Bishop of Paris sustained Tahu
Trotta seed 1900 was garden officer
alersa perspectiva sobre Brazil no Ali
are estranged arrow but a contributor
busca to PI is a planar tinge meters of
achievers negotiate the state velocity
starts parched Accord no Cavell sadaqa
zone no stones Aubry achieve Quattro
tries to compromise a cigarette because
inclusive ik equal to achieve equality -
then being marches into does Dan also
construe so from over oportunidad
uplands larger longer davido plateau de
toads NASA lenient Rock experience
internal so nice as analysis in chief
because especially do some fundamentals
pro compare maintenance on all these
compromises amid the lattice usually arc
reach peace in chief mr. anno complement
arrow complement fit pros or cons public
no so nice
communists are those Colossians 3 all
the pleasure made proper mr. DeLuca so
Nelson Cheatham desert Mirage
electricity metal to play national
judoka so provided ambient noise music
original brazil intrusive agility the
promise on meniscus in chief kokuto a
technological pious intent gases in his
achievers possibility at leas organizing
Universidad central pesky the germs of
spices probes involvement winter
Columbus a bit nervous but perspective
Arena District associative cat lava
mirroring endangerment to move to for
tells me that since the Jerome's
auspices open so many achieve
opportunity president arm poco break
hipoteca Naqada do governor jay
transistor insta matt resistant govt
know he is a famous SES approximate so
international mother's pretty dad's
bridge in terms of particular concern
was the Imperial status of or Missoni
hedge basically the cc2 has employed up
our city into investor Gao from de
Senado cruise aquí está de pluie
professor meter mayor LaVon Hayes SH
majors in our College parcel United saw
public key to preserve concierge remodel
contributing causes she moves ice to the
Brazilian studs
I mean it's 13 Salvatori I mention ago
shall perservere confront associate
Allah Vargas give give I sent important
if you commute fellows Utama delegate so
Akita from the sound present leader odd
applause oh please danger place to join
this event be the most reminds me
where's a helluva strategic ado team so
they stood Brazilian star zuni's hatch
become assigned opposing contrition maya
kalampore to be as a drum of CL do
brasil applica me opera quincy me to Dan
Oster literature arts sing como ballpark
the no support songs in chief conceived
of it in Osasuna versa dads who gods in
periodicals not-so-nice receptor so easy
test some class you can gain to skaters
me luigi pursuers from on to português
endomondo humid as in his achievers g
involve eita being as a person
inter-community dodgy despise jingle
portuguese a post which may encounter
observing the importance to portuguese
know so many modalities critic emotive
may allow mr. Coonan fundamental Pisgah
gcamp
me and being so public eye arch I think
it comes como limited the Posada
crescendo meter to public a so he's not
so nice in English at spawn Eva sprechen
suit a Cinco Mohican same importance as
políticas not-so-nice federa Chivas
mobility international accessories
similar pesky so super Brazil Jim
maracas professor documents mais
importance to do customer badness oh no
common curricula as instance Pony Belize
underwater terrain aversive English trap
or the troca Queens made to eat he turn
to do is you know fundamental
contradiction homage a scientist on the
confer Instagram Grenada bar Chi Minh
entering entry nozzles
entry knows yesterday but no Evo
Veeraswamy knows confidence in Cadiz on
tomochka - todos presence aqui continua
Ramos olvidos remote observe our Mayo
sparse areas pecan Tribune astute sober
Brazil no queremos que si de batz in
strange a zombie ng in SS dorias na
synthezoids Pollard's cozy on debauch
pesquisa a Formica table is amazing
things profit progress a toads key
contributor
Nessus the barges nASA says the
systematic extermination is delicious as
history administered Paducah so at
present concerts post on investor Gao
domain demise presents present she
contribute on site Porter nests
importance projeto yachts kill the main
sewage inning Nava mainship restore Agra
DSO universe da ga obrigado toads
[Applause]
[Music]
secretary Sigala
ambassador Pyatt ambassador my deal in a
Pierrot President Samuelson Liao a
professor cloud revile every visiting
scholars colleagues ladies and gentlemen
this conference at Yale Brazilian
studies in the United States the road
ahead marks one of the most
comprehensive reviews of studies of
Brazil in the United States to be
undertaken since the first doctoral
degrees were awarded in American
universities for studies in Brazil
almost 70 years ago and the first
international colloquium of loser
Brazilian studies met in October 1950 at
the Library of Congress with a presence
of such figures as Serge Ibaka Yolanda
Joseon our teacher who'd Regas Cecilia
alias Helen Caldwell Ralph Dimmick and
Antonio Kundu recent research by darling
II sadly a in her book Americans all
follows a generation of Brazilian
intellectuals invited to the United
States in the 1940s and 50s under the
good-neighbor policy whose present set
the stage for the wave of visiting
professors teaching in US universities
under the NDEA act of 1959 studies of
Brazil in that first phase in our
universities
belong primarily to the social sciences
and in 1966 historian Robert Levine
published a guide to research titled
Brazil field research guide and the
Social Sciences the first comprehensive
study of Brazilian Escala Brazil came to
be called was Rosa Carlos a b-bow may
his 1990 book
interviews a colonia Brazilian East the
Brazilian Escala knee
today's yell conference comes almost 20
years after the meetings at the
Brazilian Embassy in Washington DC in
1999 under ambassador paulo Tarson
fleshie de lima his objective was to
establish interaction with the academic
community in the United States on an
official level and which gave rise to
the publication of brazil's brazilian
Easter's in gear disaster the sir brazil
dos Estados Unidos miller since the
quiddity cinco boys meal and its
counterpart in english envisioning
brazil a guide to Brazilian studies in
the United States 1945 to 2000 those by
national studies continued to be limited
in scope to the humanities arts social
sciences education and library science
the last general review of studies of
Brazilian United States was conducted in
2005 by the Brazilian studies
association with the aim of assessing
and promoting traditional fields of
study for the first time and distinct
from previous meetings on Brazilian
studies the Yale conference assigns
priority to the sciences particularly
public health medicine and the
environment alongside the humanities
arts and social sciences in addition our
purpose is to provide structural models
for the study of Brazil in the United
States based on active collaborative
research tied to institutions in Brazil
our aim is to establish linkages that
will aid future researchers recognize
their work in both countries and provide
a framework for associations among
scholars and institutions for the future
our work today was prepared by the May
conference at Yale in which more than a
dozen specialists on Brazil presented
papers on their own research covering
studies in ethnomusicology anthropology
history literature forestry biomedical
research and public health for this
november event scholars will debate
central questions affecting their
research and discuss models for
improving by national cooperation as
well as consider the evolving nature of
their fields our goal is to produce a
book on these discussions that will
provide helpful advice and directions
for another generation of
scholars of Brazil and the United States
this conference itself is a
collaborative effort between the mini
standard advocacy cell and Yale
University
with pleasure I recognize the presence
of the National deputy executive
secretary Felipe's Arthur Siegel
I would like also to think the personnel
of the ministry for receiving me for a
planning session in Brasilia in February
and for a second meeting and regenitive
and July supported by UNESCO this
conference is the outcome of many
combined efforts at the Ministry of
Education I would like to recognize
Minister Carlebach azúcar Nadeau
assisted by Maria Audion a Pinto Janice
and Gustavo sorvita
who's here today thanks also to dr.
Sergio Guerra Dean of the law school of
the food nostalgia to the Vargas for our
productive meeting in July which led to
the participation by the foundation and
the present and the presence of its
president this conference could not have
been organized without the truly
efficient and perceptive organization of
Miss Asian opening of Yale's Council of
Latin American and Iberian studies
assisted by Blair Nelson and Daniel
wadis and in Brasilia by Gustavo
Servilia our work at Yale for Brazil in
Connecticut has enjoyed the support of
the Brazilian consulate in Hartford an
ambassador for another millibar here too
for which we are especially grateful it
has been an honor for me to work with
all of you and organizing the road ahead
and I would like to welcome especially
the many scholars and specialists in
Brazil about whose experience and
collaborative research we will soon
learn Yale has a long and memorable role
in Brazilian studies in 1908 Brazil's
first time better ambassador to the
United States Rocky Nabucco came to
campus for two lectures the place of
calm voice and literature and the spirit
of nationality in Brazil Nabucco slice
of the kamon Ian epoch is evidence that
literature nourished his relationship
with political culture which he
understood an aesthetic parameters
Karolina Nabucco wrote in her biography
quote to reveal caboose to the Americans
was to promote the Portuguese language
and to treat one of his favorite
subjects
the love of caboose that at age 20 had
inspired his first book Kamui's
uselessness accompanied him his whole
life
end of quote now buca's presentation on
nationality shares its content with
machado de assis and his famous essay
instinctive nationality seeing in
brazilian life a recapitulation sua
generous of the great art types of
Western civilization
he thought that universal values of
culture had to be built over a long
period of apprenticeship rather than
simply located in national identity for
an abacus imagination Brazil is one of
the stages of the human drama and he
expected spectator in recognition of
Nabucco lectures at Yale the seminar
shrieky Nabucco at Yale statesmen author
ambassador a centenary symposium
commemorating the lectures at Yale and
1908 brought scholars and many members
of a Nabucco family to Yale in April of
2008 today and recognition of nobuko's
love of kumoi's the by Nikki rare books
and manuscripts library exhibited the
first edition of Isla siddhis and the
Reema's advancement of studies in Brazil
and the Portuguese language at Yale date
from the late 19th century with a
philologist and medievalist Henri
Roseman Lange and continued with such
scholar teachers as Malcolm Bachelor
college campus Richard Morse and Amelia
V watching the zoo that custom we owe
our accomplishments as scholars of
Brazil to several generations of us
Brazilian Easter's whose work and
dedication to Brazilian studies has
brought us to this point today in 1938
for example American anthropologist Ruth
Landis traveled alone to self-abort
Bahia for a year's research and in her
book city of women commented on the
restrictive policies she encountered at
the same time she expressed her
admiration for and confidence in the
Brazilian people and her admiration for
its liberal social attitudes in
comparison with the u.s. at the time in
the 54 years since I first visited
Brazil I have seen many changes and
difficulties however I continue to be
fascinated by Brazilian
and like other Brazilian easties who
were committed to the study of Brazil I
have confidence in the road ahead on
behalf of the Portuguese program and
Brazilian cities at Yale I welcome you
here and wish you a successful
conference and a memorable visit to Yale
thank you very much good afternoon to
everyone it's a pleasure to be here
today representing for myself
Julia Vargas this day fdv is a 70 year
old institution it's not as old as you
see a it is not an university but we
have several schools and we have many
fields of research mostly in the social
sciences I would like to thank yearly
University through the ill Office of
International Affairs the through the
Yale Macmillan Centre Council of
latin-american Iberian studies I would
also like to thank the Brasilia office
of UNESCO the Ministry of Education of
Brazil I'm very happy to be here indeed
not only as president of FGM of GV but
also as an intellectual observer I come
here not only to maybe give a small help
on you trying to understand us and
believe me I haven't yet done such a
thing but also to understand how you
understand us which is more important
from us than really understanding
ourselves
Brazil is
today at a very interesting point in
this history my opinion is that we ended
the cycle this has several implications
possibly we have gone back to a more
traditional course and maybe tomorrow at
the end of our similar I will speak
about this anyway it is a great pleasure
to listen to people that have dedicated
their lives to study my country let me
tell you that I admire all of you that
do this it will be a great pleasure for
me and for all my people that are here
to interact with you I'm not a historian
I'm not a political scientist I am NOT a
lawyer I'm a simple engineer who helped
us to know a little bit of economics and
but I will gladly helped by my
colleagues help discuss any issue there
is that we can help you as you possibly
know fgv in brazil excels in many areas
so and here you have some of the best
people at fgv not me
then so thank you very much and it is
really a great pleasure to be here today
[Applause]
[Music]